j'ouvre le second débat de ce sens
public consacré à la crise de
l'immobilier les ventes sont en baisse
les taux d'intérêt reste élevé avec un
effet domino sur les biens en location
de plus en plus rare avant de voir si
cette crise est vraiment historique si
elle est mondiale ou franco-française et
quel levier activé pour en sortir le
constat avec Cécile
Sixou vous aimeriez acheter votre
logement mais les prix et les taux
d'intérêt vous rebutent vous n'êtes pas
les seuls dans ce cas cette année le
marché de immobilier est en mauvaise
santé et les ventes sont en berne avec
875000 transactions en 2023 c'est 22 %
de vente en moins qu'en 2022 en cause
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt de 2,5
% à 4 % et parallèlement la très faible
baisse des prix de l'immobilier de 1,8 %
un ratio un suffisant pour redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux Français la hausse
des taux mais aussi une légère
correction des prix fait que que le
pouvoir d'achat immobilier en France en
moyenne c'est Mo- 7 m² et
particulièrement dans les villes du Sud
he des villes comme nîes des villes
comme Toulon là la baisse est très forte
hein parce que les prix ont continué
d'augmenter dans ces zonesl on a perdu
beaucoup de mètres carrés jusqu'à 20 m²
en un an difficile d'acheter mais aussi
de louer les biens sur le marché sont
devenus une denrée rare avec la crise du
crédit les Primot accédant attendent une
baisse des prix pour acheter et ne
quittent plus leur logement autre
blocage la modification des normes
imposées aux investisseurs immobiliers
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de normes
qui empêchent des des gens d'investir au
fond dans la pierre pour louer ensuite
des logements et ça ça pénalise l'accès
à la location et donc de notre point de
vue c'est probablement le premier levier
qu'il faut activer pour permettre
finalement que tout le monde ait un toit
sur la tête en 2024 la situation devrait
se normaliser selon Guillaume otier car
les premiers signes montrent une baisse
des taux et un ajustement des prix du
marché quel sont les causes profondes de
cette crise du logement et les moyens à
sortir on en débat avec Sandra wabian
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes docteur en
sociologie et directrice générale du
Crédoc le centre de recherche pour
l'étude et l'observation des conditions
de vie pierre mec bonsoir et bienvenue
économiste à l'Observatoire des
conjonctures économiques et spécialistes
de l'immobilier du logement j'accueille
claire Julia bonsoir et bienvenue vous
êtes sociologue spécialiste de la ville
du logement et des marchés immobiliers
et chercheuse indépendante consultante
en immobilier Mathieu croissand d'au
évidemment est resté à mes côtés
peut-être un premier chiffre pour ouvrir
notre débat sur les les ventes de
logements anciens le bilan de l'année
2023 vient de tomber 875000 ventes c'est
moin 22 % par rapport à l'année
2022 on parle de crise historique on
reviendra peut-être sur ce terme Sandra
wabian mais qui sont les premières
victimes de cette crise on parle de qui
plutôt les primos accédents qui qui sont
les les principales ou les premières
victimes alors tout dépend quel est le
référentiel si on est sur le sur le le
court terme vraiment sur la crise
vraiment récente c'est plutôt
effectivement les Primot accédent ceux
qui n'ont pas de côté déjà ou déjà mis
un premier pred dans dans la propriété
et donc qui n'ont pas en fait de de
montant minimal pour ensuite se lancer
sur sur le marché de la de
l'acquisition maintenant si on regarde
un petit peu plus sur le long terme bah
ceux qui sont le plus en difficulté sur
le marché du logement c'est les primau
accédents les jeunes les foyers de
personnes seul donc on peut aussi avoir
des personnes un peu plus agés toutes
les personnes qui sont plutôt avec des
bas revenus donc des des foyers qui en
fait ont des revenus qui sont pas
suffisants pour accéder à la propriété
et de plus en plus aussi difficile
d'accéder au à la location oui alors on
y reviendra là-dessus parce que c'est
vraiment un des éléments importants je
trouve de de ce débat est-ce que
finalement le la la situation logement
est un accélérateur de d'inégalité on y
consacrera une une partie un chapitre
mais à quel point je voudrais rester sur
le constat pierre mec d'après vous à
quel point cette crise est grave
historique est-ce que c'est un mot un
peu galvodé ou ou justifié alors je
pense qu'elle est historique je par
contre je suis pas sûr que l'indicateur
de regarder le nombre de ventre dans
l'ancien soit un bon indicateur il y en
a d'autres on en prendra d'autres aussi
non mais dans dans le sens où en fait un
peu plus de 800000 transactions dans
l'ancien c'est la norme on a connu des
années post covid notamment
exceptionnell en nombre nombre de
transaction on a passé le million on a
passé le million ça c'était exceptionnel
donc de ce point de vue là va falloir
falloir que ça s'arrête évidemment cette
dégradation du nombre de de biens
échangés mais ce chiffre là en tant que
tel est pas très inquiétant là où c'est
historique c'est on a jamais connu en
France des niveaux de prix aussi élevés
avec des niveaux de taux aussi élevés
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup d'observateurs
qui disent c'est pas très grave des taux
à 4 % des taux à 3 et demi on en a déjà
connu et ça s'est très bien passé c'est
vrai mais c'était dans un contexte où il
y avait un pouvoir d'achat des ménages
qui était très dynamique et il y avait
des niveaux de prix immobilier qui
étaient bien plus bas là aujourd'hui on
est dans une situation où bah il y a un
attentisme généralisé parce qu'il y a
une désolvabilisation massive des
ménages on a a des niveaux de prix
historiquement haut malgré le fait qu'il
baisse un tout petit peu des niveaux de
taux très élevés et un pouvoir d'achat
des des ménages qui s'est un peu érodé
sur la période récente et c'est ça qui
rend à mon avis la crise historique euh
il y a aussi le marché du neuf qui est
en grande
difficulté claire Julia est-ce que on
risque par exemple des plans de
licenciement chez de de grands
promoteurs immobiliers est-ce qu'on est
à ce niveau de de de crise évidemment
c'est c'est complexe le marché du
logement he il y en a voilà il y a
l'ancien il y a le neuf il y a la
location on va essayer de parler de tout
ça mais comment vous vous évaluez la
gravité de cette crise alors moi je j'ai
tendance à me méfier des des discours de
de crise oui euh parce que ils vont
toujours dans le sens de l'inédit en
fait quand on est frappé par une crise
euh on on on on produit des discours un
peu toutou fait de rupture euh on pointe
des des des situations tout à fait
inédites et c'est vrai que la crise que
nous traversons a quelques symptômes
quelques indicateurs assez inédits la B
baisse des des prix en fait partie euh
sur le 9 évidemment la baisse
considérable euh des livraisons mais
aussi le taux d'écoulement les
difficultés d'écoulement des stocks font
partie de ces indicateurs un petit peu
euh symptomatique et inédite cette crise
mais je crois qu'une crise euh elle a
intérêt à être mise dans le temps long
en fait euh notamment des dynamiques de
marché et puis des tendances de société
et à ce titre euh si le constat de cette
crise consiste euh à à comment dire à
souligner les difficultés d'accès à la
propriété des ménages des difficultés
d'accès au locatif privé et social des
ménages mais aussi de souligner les
difficultés que rencontrent les
professionnels de l'immobilier vous
parlez des prur c'est ce que vous allez
nous dire ça c'est du long c'est du
structurel d'une certaine façon ou c'est
du structurel ça fait 20 ans que ça dure
en fait enfin euh sur les effets sur les
ménages sont à peu près alors on peut
les qualifier structurel en tout cas ils
sont durables ça fait 20 ans queon
assiste dans un contexte de hausse
considérable des prix d'immobilier à des
difficultés croissantes alors je vais
donner un autre chiffre c'est le chiffre
sur les les nouveaux prêts à l'habitat
accordés en 2023 130 milliards d'euros
alors ça peut sembler très important
sauf que c'est moins 40 % par rapport à
l'année précédente et d'ailleurs à
l'occasion de d'une série d'auditions
organisé au Sénat le le mois dernier
avant la publication de ces chiffres le
président de la Fédération nationale de
l'immobilier était inquiet sur la la la
hausse des taux d'intérêt il espérait la
fin de cette hausse n sommes très
certainement à un moment historique où
nous allons être confrontés à la plus
grande crise du logement que nous nayons
connu et je crois depuis l'après-gerre
si entendre lis chapeau les Tau reste
stable je l'espère je le souhaite mais
nous ne sommes pas nous pouvons être à
la veille aussi de redémarrage des taux
et rien ne laisse présager d'écarter
cette cette situation alors bien
évidemment la situation est grave parce
que je crois que le détonnateur
principal a été l'augmentation subite
des taux et de façon très rapide qui ont
largement mis à mal la capacité de
remboursement des ménages français et et
notamment fait stopper à la fois
l'investissement dans le neuf et le
parcours résidentiel des Français qui
s'est vu interrompu pierre Mad question
beaucoup de français qui nous regardent
doivent se poser c'est pour quand la
baisse des taux d'intérêt c'est pas
facile d'y répondre je suis d'accord
avec vous je peux pas ne pas la poser
non les taux se stabilise là et devrait
potentiellement baisser d'ici la fin
d'année après dans quelle proportion ça
n'est pas en capacité de le dire et
c'est surtout que les prix ne s'ajustant
pas les taux reviendront jamais au
niveau qu'on a connu avant la remontée
des taux ces taux-l ils étaient
historiquement très faibles anormalement
anormalement faible oui euh on reviendra
peut-être après sur à qui a profité cet
assouplissement massif des conditions de
crédit parce que c'est important de
rappeler que cet assouplissement il a
pas bénéficié à tout le monde et ces
volumes historiques de crédit à
l'habitat distribués ils ont pas été
distribués à tout le monde on aura
sûrement l'occasion d'y revenir si on
parle un peu inégalité donc on
retrouvera jamais les niveaux de taux
d'avant la remontée des taux et donc il
semble inéluctable que les prix doivent
s'ajuster si on veut rolvabiliser
massivement les ménages alors justement
Sandra waban les les bon les prix
logement qui baissent qui commence à à à
à baisser on comprend les propriétaires
qui sont inquiets de voir leur leur
patrimoine un peu fond mais est-ce que
c'est forcément une mauvaise nouvelle
non pour l'ensemble de la population
c'est pas une mauvaise nouvelle c'est
comme vous le dites très bien ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui propriétaires ils sont
en moyenne un peu plus âgé que la
moyenne des Français ils sont aussi un
peu plus aisés que la moyenne des
Français et donc ils ont par ailleurs on
va dire eu des conditions de vie qui
étaient aussi un accès à l'emploi qui
était un petit peu plus facile
donc le fait que aujourd'hui il a
constitué un patrimoine très important
que si les prix commencent un petit peu
à diminuer d'une certaine manière c'est
un peu un rééquilibrage et on devrait
pouvoir permettre ainsi aux nouvelles
générations de pouvoir rentrer sur le
marché du logement donc le fait que prix
fluidité d'une certaine façon ça peut
mettre de la fluidité c'estàdire que les
prix sont tellement élevés aujourd'hui
que tout le marché est bloqué à la fois
le marché de l'accession à la propriété
mais par effet de ricocher également la
location donc et tout ça ça a été un peu
perfusé par les Tau bas dont on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
tellement peur après la crise de 2008
que tout que le queil y ait plus du tout
de liquidité que on a injecté de
l'argent pas cher et qu'on a comme ça
maintenu la dynamique d'achat mais
aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec une
sorte de nouvelle fracture sociale entre
d'un côté des propriétaires qui ont un
patrimoine qui s'est plutôt apprécié et
donc en fait le patrimoine d'une
certaine manière a plus de valeur
aujourd'hui que la valeur du travail on
parle beaucoup de la valeur travail dans
notre société mais avoir acheté un
logement à la bonne époque ça permet
d're beaucoup plus enrichi que le
travail donc une fracture entre ceux qui
sont propriétaires et ceux qui
n'arrivent pas à rentrer sur le marché
de l'AC alors justement CLIRE vous nous
parliez du du pardon Mathieu vou
intervenir allez-y non j'ai juste une
question en fait parce que il y a des
raisons conjoncturelles que vous avez
très bien écrit qui qui expliquent le
ralentissement et le marché immobilier
il est aussi porté par des des des
mouvements structurels qui ont rés
souvent les 3D le les décès les divorces
les déménagements est-ce que ça veut
dire que cette population là qui peut
être chacun d'entre nous qui est touché
par des événement de la vie est aussi
attentiste ou
il y a un effet sur ce sur G les gens
divorcent moins les gens sur les
facteurs de de long terme vous avez
raison ça devrait pas s'arrêter
c'est-à-dire qu'on a de moins en moins
de nombre de personnes par foyer ça ne
fait que diminuer parce qu'on vieillit
parce qu'on a plus de période de célibat
parce qu'on s'est mis à divorcé à 50 ans
ce qui était pas le cas par le passé
donc tout ça fait que la demande en fait
de logement est importante et aussi
parce qu'on habite des logements plus
grands on le dit pas très souvent mais
on a aussi cette cette cette expansion
en fait des des tailles des logements
qui fait qu'on a aussi un peu plus de de
confort on fait pas que perdre le
système cl Juliard il est un peu grippé
il y il y a beaucoup de Français qui
voudrai bien bouger changer
d'appartement changer de maison et qui
peuvent pas ou pourrait presque faire
une liste quoi d'une certaine façon des
Figur on peut lister tout un tas de de
de situations assez symptomatiques de
cette crise au long cours en fait qui
touche le logement et ses conditions
d'accès on peut citer je sais pas les
jeunes qui qui peineent à décoabiter et
qui sont coincés chez leurs parents on
peut citer aussi je sais pas les
familles qui doivent renoncer adapter
leur logement à la naissance de leurs
enfants on peut citer
cabit exactement on peut évidemment
citer les familles
monoparentales qui sont confrontés à
d'énormes difficultés et qui peuvent
faire le choix de la colocation plutôt
que du logement autonome par nécessité
on peut citer je sais pas les salariés
également qui peinent à se rapprocher de
leur l de travail on peut citer leurs
entreprises qui peinent à recruter faute
et donc là on prend vraiment la mesure
de ce que de ce que un marché du du de
l'immobilier grippé il y a un effet
domino quoi d'une certaine façon
absolument absolument et puis en fait
quand on cite toutes ces catégories de
population on cite pas encore les
personnes de plus en plus nombreuses qui
sont victimes du mallogement hein la
Fondation abépierre va rendre son
rapport annuel sur l'état du mallogement
dans quelques semaines on l'attend tous
on s'attend tous à un constat assez
assez dramatique bon pierre mec à quel
point si on regarde le temps long là
aussi la la progression de des prix des
logements sur plusieurs décennies c'est
déconnecté de la de de la hausse des des
revenus par exemple des Français
clairement c'est depuis le début des
années 2000 c'est on parle beaucoup de
la baisse des taux en effet intervenu
après la la crise de de 2008 mais faut
voir que avant la baisse des taux il y a
quelque chose qui a énormément
solvabilisé les ménages c'est
l'allongement des durées d'emprunt et ça
c'est depuis le début des années 2000 en
gros où la durée moyenne des emprunts
pour acheter son logement a beaucoup
augmenté les gens se sont endettés pour
acheter leur résidence principale sur
des temps beaucoup plus longs et ça ça
ça été une machine à solvabilisation ce
qui est intéressant dans dans la liste
qui vient d'être faite c'est queon voit
bien c'est pas nouveau en les les jeunes
ont pas attendu la crise immobilière
récente ou la crise de la construction
pour avoir des difficultés les millions
de ménages mal logés ils sont là depuis
extrêmement longtemps aussi et ce qu'on
voit c'est que on avait un marché qui en
effet pendant très longtemps était non
pas sous perfusion d'argent public comme
certains pourraient le dire mais sous
perfusion de conditions de crédit très
favorable et donc ça a maintenu un
espèce d'équilibre comme ça où il y
avait un nombre de transactions qui
étaient extrêmement important des prix
immobiliers orientés à la hausse et donc
on avait l'impression que tout allait
bien là en réalité ce qu'on ce qu'on
voit avec la crise actuelle je sais pas
si elle est inédite ou historique mais
ce qu'elle montre c'est que on a une
crise structurelle qui est
extrêmement difficile importante la
question des Airbnb elle a pas attendu
le covid pour se poser la question des
résidences secondaires non plus et donc
plus que euh à l'état conjoncturel du
marché où il faut il faut évidemment
soutenir le le secteur de la
construction neuve mais il faut s'
atttaquer à mon avis au cause
structurell de la crise du logement qui
traverse la France depuis 20 ou 30 ans
maintenant ouais alors on a évoqué
l'effet domino on va parler un peu de la
location maintenant et je vous propose
une rapide revue de presse de titre sur
les les les on va dire on pourrait
résumer ça en parlant de la galère des
des
locataires donc ça c'est un 1100
demandes en en 4 He on a aussi des des
agences qui ne publient plus d'annonces
le nombre d'annonces de maisons et
d'appartements àoués en chute libre et
puis aussi il y a un
effet collatéral si j'ose dire avec de
plus en plus de de locataires qui enfin
ou d'aspirants locataires qui pour
réussir à obtenir un logement falsifie
leur leur dossier et ça on en voit de
plus en plus dans les dans les
agences comment on peut caractériser ça
Sandra waban c'est un c'est une sorte
d'assèchement du marché là en ce moment
alors ça c'est peut-être conjoncturel
mais c'est réeloui de de manière plus
conjoncturelle il y a différents
facteurs qui ralentissent l'accès au
logement par exemple le télétravail le
fait qu'on travaille chez soi et donc
besoin de plus grand surface par ça fait
qu'il y a une pression sur la demande on
peut aussi parler des de tous les
diagnostics qu'il faut les notamment le
DP qui fait que ça peut ralentir la mise
sur le marché parce que si on n' pas un
logement au NME on est censé ne pas
pouvoir bientôt le le le le le louer
Bonou même temps en même temps on peut
pas laisser les passoirs termiques euh
proliférer comme comme c'était le cas
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr mais c'est en
fait le problème c'est qu'on a de plus
en plus de bailleurs privés donc des
petits bailleurs qui possèdent quelques
logements et donc avant le logement
était beaucoup plus possédé par des
institutions et donc rénover leur parc
qui faisaient un voilà qui avaient un
travail un peu plus professionnel
lorsqu'on est un petit bailleur c'est
pas évident de se lancer dans les
travaux pour rénover son son le logement
qu'on qu'on met en location donc on a
aussi des effets comme ça structurel et
ça ça peut durer longtemps peut-être
d'un mot euh pierre Malec bah ça peut
durer longtemps parce que la dynamique
est ancienne et tant qu'on a pas résolu
le bout de la chaîne l'accession à la
propriété c'est le bout de la chaîne
c'est le bout du parcours résidentiel si
les ménages accèdent moins à la
propriété forcément il reste plus
locataire que ce soit locataire du parc
social ou du parc privé donc il libère
pas de logement et comme on était déjà
sur un secteur en crise sur le marché la
location privée notamment dans les
grandes métropoles si on règle pas le
bout de la chaîne on va pas résoudre non
plus la question du marché locatif priv
alors vous disiez crise structurelle
l'un et l'autre donc on va se poser la
question des solutions de ce qu'un état
un gouvernement peut faire en la matière
mais d'abord Mathieu on va partir d'un
constat il n'y avait pas de ministre du
logement dans le gouvernement qui a été
dévoilé jeudi non c'est pas un accident
bien au contraire c'est devenu une
habitude sous Emmanuel Macron dans les
premières moutures des gouvernements il
y a pas de ministre du Logement ce fut
le cas lors du premier gouvernement
Philippe comme lors du premier
gouvernement borne et désormais lors du
gouvernement àal alors bien sûr ça pas
empêché par la suite de voir le
portefeuille occupé par Julien de
Normandie d'abord puis Emmanuel vargon
puis Olivier clin puis Patrice vergrit
mais cette Vals des titulaires tout
comme le rang de Ministre délégués ou
non pas de ministre de pleine exercice
montre bien que c'est pas une
préoccupation numéro 1 de l'exécutif
comment vous l'expliquer ben c'est
incompréhensible on vient de le dire
nous sommes face à une crise majeure et
historique probablement du logement
c'est une des premières préoccupations
des français même si est pas forcément
dite comme tel mais quand on parle du
pouvoir d'achat c'est généralement aussi
pouvoir d'achat pour se loger puisquon
sait que ça prend quand même un bon
tiers voir
plus du pouvoir d'achat des Français le
secteur du bâtiment c'est quand même un
des premiers secteurs économique en
nombre de salariés mais nommeré un
ministre du Logement son visiblement
moins important est moins urgent euh que
nommer par exemple une porte-parole du
du du gouvernement puisque là pour le
coup il y en a une alors signe des temps
avec cet oubli l'exécutif a réussi à se
mettre à dos la quasi totalité de la
filière les acteurs du logement social
comme ceux de la promotion immobilière
les fédérations de propriétaires comme
les associations de locataires tout le
monde s'élève contre le peu de cas que
l'exécutif fait de leurs problème voire
il voit même un signe de déconnex entre
des gens qui n'auraient jamais eu de
problème à se loger et puis la réalité
de ce que vivent les Français parce
qu'en fait tout à ça volonté d'afficher
un gouvernement resserré pour des
raisons de pure communication pour le
coup hein l'exécutif a fait passer le
logement comme la santé d'ailleurs au
second plan alors ça c'est l'acte de
choisir rapidement ou non un ministre ou
une ministre du Logement mais mais sur
les réformes est-ce que la le logement a
été est une priorité de l'exécutif non
euh il ne l'a jamais été malgré les
discours et les engagements ça avait mal
commencé vous en souvenez juste pour le
symbole des 2017 avec cette décision de
rogner les appel pour boucler le budget
il y a eu des efforts ensuite he il y a
eu des lois il y a eu des budgets en
augmentation mais rien de systémique
pour reprendre une expression euh à la
MODEF ce que vous disiez un changement
structurel logement en fait il a été
considéré euh sous son angle fiscal avec
par exemple la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation sous l'angle écologique ou
énergétique avec tout ce qu'on a pu voir
sur le DPE et et tout ça l'accent il a
été mis sur l'emploi le gouvernement
considérant un peu vite que si on
résorbit le chômage ben on reviendrait à
bout de de tous les mots de la société
mais le fameux choc d'offre vous
souvenez de cette expression promis par
Emmanuel Macron pour faire baisser les
prix de l'immobilier et permettre à tous
d'accéder à un logement ben il n'a
jamais eu lieu le nombre de construction
de logements sociaux a chuté depuis 2017
l'IDEM pour le nombre de mise en
chantier de logement de biens collectifs
comme de biens
individuels je vous dis le un CNR il y a
eu un CNR voilà qui a rendu un conseil
national de la refondation voilà sur le
logement qui de dont le les conclusions
ont longtemps été décalé puisque c'était
prévu de mémoire pour le début de
l'année 2023 puis finalement ça été le 5
juin 23 euh après donc plusieurs mois de
travail euh ils se sont fixés comme
objectif de redonner aux Français du
pouvoir d'habiter C expression à mon
avis ça sonne un peu comme le pouvoir
d'achat mais plutôt que de passer des
mois à inventer des formules creuse je
pense que l'exécutif aura mieux fait de
passer quelques jours à trouver un
ministre et une politique oui claire
Juliard est-ce que c'est pas parce que
le les effets d'une peut-être que je me
trompe hein je suis loin d'être
spécialiste comme vous mais d'une
politique du logement ils sont sur le
long terme sur le très long terme voz ce
que je veux dire quand on est politique
on cherche à avoir un retour sur
investissement rapide est-ce que vous
l'expliquez comme ça
euh oui effectivement les effets de la
politique de logement il se il se joue
sur le long terme enfin le logement
c'est c'est c'est du temps long ouais la
production du logement c'est c'est du
temps long c'est pas du temps politique
en tout cas à première enfin en premier
abord au premier abord on peut faire de
la politique avec ce thème du logement
vous voyez ce que je veux dire là on a
un Gabriel Atal qui arrive on l'a dit
dans notre premier débat attendu sur
l'efficacité sur des actes et pas
seulement de la la communication
qu'est-ce que vous qui connaissez très
bien ce ce secteur euh qu'est-ce qui
pourrait être un peu emblématique
politiquement on on a longtemps fait
logement un objet de de politique public
euh d'ailleurs il reste quand même un
objet de de politique publique le l'État
intervient de maintes manièrees auprès
euh des constructeurs des ménages euh de
l'ensemble de l'écosystème
euh
euh je pense que ça reste oui un un bel
objet de politique publique à réinvestir
euh les derniers choix les dernières
mesures qui ont été prises par notre
ministou c'est quoi c un peu trop
pointilliste d'après vous euh non je
crois qu'elles étaient surtout jugé
comme comme susceptible de dégrader
encore les conditions d'accès au
logement euh de dégrader encore l'offre
locative avec l'extinction notamment du
du Pinel qui est un dispositif
incitatif d'investissement à la location
votre avis là-dessus je pose la même
question pierre madc est-ce qu'il y a un
choix politique à faire là aujourd'hui
ce qui intéressant est-ce qu'il a
différentes alternatives voyez ce que je
veux dire ce qui est intéressant c'est
que je pense qu'en effet c'est compliqué
pour un responsable politique au niveau
national de s'inscrire dans un discours
politique sur le logement parce qu'en
effet bah vous décidez pas et on l'a vu
par le passé de construire 500000
logements du jour au lendemain d'accord
par contre donc ça c'est oui c'est c'est
un temps long par contre ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir que des
décisions politiques qui ont été prises
sur la politique du logement au cours
des dernières années ilells ont eu des
résultats immédiats euh la réduction de
l' de solidarité donc couper de l'argent
aux bailleurs sociaux ça fait moins de
logement social baisser les aides
personnelles au logement c'est une
dégradation de la situation financière
des ménages immédiatement la fin du
Pinel ou la fin du PTZ ça va se traduire
par moins de logement
produit pardon prate au zéro euh donc ça
s'inscrit sur du temps long mais on voit
bien quand on fait des coupes
budgétaires là euh il y a des résultats
à très court terme ou juste un point sur
euh ce qu'on peut faire très rapidement
oui aujourd'hui sans faire de la
démagogie hein il y a des enfants qui
dorment dehors le soir alors qu'il fait
froid il y a des gens qui meurent à la
rue ça c'est c'est l'état c'est il faut
ouvrir des places massivement des places
d'hébergement d'urgence c'est pas de la
politique du logement c'est pas du temps
long c'est là dans l'urgence il faut
faire quelque chose et pour ça il faut
un ministre du Logement et on consacrera
d'ailleurs un un débat à ce thème précis
dans dans quelques jours dans dans dans
sens public je reviens sur le la
perception cendrabian des des Français
face à cette thématique parce que quand
on regarde les priorités des Français le
thème logement alors évidemment c'est
peut-être dans le pouvoir d'achat
Mathieu a raison mais le thème logement
il apparaît pas quasiment jamais est-ce
que c'est pas une autre explication de
de ce relatif désintérêts de de des
politiques parce que c'est vrai
d'Emmanuel Macron mais les prédécesseur
était pas non plus ministre bon il y
avait un ministre il y en aa d'ailleurs
il
alégé faut quand même rappeler qu'il y a
60 % des Français qui sont propriétaires
de leur logement donc ils ont une forme
de sécurité alors leur logement peut
être un peu dégradé hein on peut être
propriétaire et propriétaires pauvre
hein mais globalement ils ont déjà accès
à un logement donc effectivement Dee
certaine manière ça joue pas pour le
pour le marché du logement l'autre
élément c'est que euh au-delà du du la
question du temps long il y a aussi la
question de toute la réglementation qui
est autour du logement c'est-à-dire que
quand vous voulez créer des solutions de
logement vous êtes face à par exemple
l'idée de faire du logement modulable
d'avoir des des immeubles qui puissent
être utilisés pour diff différents types
d'usage pour créer un petit peu de
fluidité c'est extrêmement compliqué
parce que les normes de sécurité pour un
établissement scolaire c'est pas les
même que pour un établissement de santé
et cetera donc c'est c'est aussi un un
sujet très technique et donc on peut pas
en 5 minutes produire des des mesures
qui vont fluidifier le marché alors
justement vous parliez du PTZ le prêt à
to Z je vous propose puisqu'on est sur
les leviers d'action potentiel d'écouter
en novembre dernier Elizabeth borne donc
encore première ministre évidemment
elle elle annonçait pardon le
prolongement j'y arrive de ce prêt à
pour répondre au resserrement du crédit
bancaire nous avons décidé de prolonger
le prêt à taux zéro jusqu'en
2027 c'est un choix fort du gouvernement
800 millions d'euros par an pour
soutenir l'accès à la propriété des
ménages modestes mais aussi des classes
moyennes puisque 6 millions de Français
supplémentaires y seront ible alors je
commence avec vous pierre madc cette
mesure est-ce qu'elle a un effet
immédiat vous vous parliez des des
effets possibles ou pas d'une d'une
action politique al rappelons que là ce
qui est annoncé c'est le maintien d'une
mesure qui existait déjà oui René un
peu juste pour remettre le le cas
supprimer le prê à taux zéro quand les
taux remontent ça sembla être une
aberration bon donc le gouvernement a en
effet fait le choix de le maintenir sous
conditions plus restrictiv ça devrait
normalement solvabiliser un un certain
nombre de ménages ça devrait soutenir le
secteur de la construction donc de ce
point de vue-là ça peut être que
accueilli positivement après il faut
rappeler que le Pr zéro ça touche très
très peu de ménag on communique beaucoup
sur le nombre de ménages éligiblebl mais
en terme de prêt distribué c'est c'est
relativement faible et encore faut-il
qu'on distribue des permis de construire
pour que les ménages puissent acheter
les les les appartements qu'on
solvabilise avec du prêt à tau zéro donc
c'est pas ça qui va non plus résoudre la
crise de la construction qui est à
l'œuvre en ce moment les les on a
commencé à l'évoquer mais je voudrais
quand même vous entendre un peu plus
longuement là-dessus claire juliia les
les inégalités face au logement elle
elle continuent de se de s'aggraver
d'une certaine façon dans notre pays
absolument oui oui les inégalités de
logement continuent de
s'aggraver en fait elle elle crée des
fractures au sein de la société enfin
voilà le les les les populations les
catégories de population sont inégales
en matière de de logement et de
conditions de logement euh je trouve que
il est aussi intéressant de de souligner
que l'immobilier est aussi très inégal
et notamment face au crise très
inégalement armé face aux crise euh
géographiquement c'estàdire que la
politique du logement elle soutient de
manière prioritaires les marchés tendus
on ça se justifie évidemment euh mais
elle a tendance de même que les analyses
qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on qu'on porte sur
l'immobilier euh voilà ont tendance à à
être être rédigé formulé d'un du point
de vue des marchés immobiliés tendus et
notamment du march par grand grand c'est
Paris et les grandes villes c'est Paris
les grandes villes et la métropole au
détriment de marché détendu qui
concentre aussi un certain nombre de
difficultés
liées déjà à des taux de vacances très
importants euh et des valorisations qui
sont et des dévalorisation très
importante qui pose voilà des questions
qui fragilisent en fait les
propriétaires cette question de de
d'inégalité face au logement une
réaction celle du sénateur socialiste de
la Somme Rémi Cardon il parle il parle
de du poids finalement de ce secteur du
logement dans dans le budget des
ménages deux chiffres quand 3,5 % des
ménages les plus aisés détiennent 50 %
des biens mis en location il y a un
problème quand en 60 ans et ça a été dit
le coût du logement pour un foyer passe
de 9,5 % des dépenses du foyer à 32%
aujourd'hui c'est trois fois plus Sandra
Wan il y a un thème que vous analysez de
avec précision c'est ce sentiment de
déclassement de de d'une partie des
Français des classes moyennes à quel
point le logement prend une part
importante làdans alors essentielle de
plusieurs raisons la première c'est
celle du pouvoir d'achat que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure c'està-dire le
fait que le poids du budget logement sur
le budget global a beaucoup augmenté
fait que mécaniquement on a moins de
marge de manœuvre donc chaque
microinflation même va avoir un effet
parce que il faut quand même se rappeler
qu'il y a eu des périodesinlationnistes
bien plus élevées que ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui mais comme le coût du
logement était moins important on
arrivait à peu près à absorber ces
hausse de prix donc très
importante sur cet effetlà et le
deuxième effet c'est sur ce qu'on
appelle le parcours résidentiel
c'est-à-dire dans les imaginaires en
gros on commence sa vie on est locataire
du petit logement mais on sait que petit
à petit on va s'installer on va accéder
à l'emploi et puis après on pourra
devenir propriétaire lorsqu'on aura on
aura envie de s'installer de de de
fonder une famille en gros ça c'est
l'imaginaire la carte d'Épinal sauf que
ça se passe plus du tout comme ça comme
les prix des logements sont très élevé
on a de moins en moins de déménagement
parce qu'en fait on va rester dans notre
logement parce que le coût le fait de
pouvoir bouger en fait va être un coût
d'abord il va falloir trouver donc c'est
pas simple ensuite le prix du mètre
carré finalement c'est beaucoup enchéri
donc on se retrouve avec des et on n pas
suffisamment d'offres de logement social
donc on se retrouve avec des parcours
résidentiels grippés des gens qui
commencent un logement social mais en
fait qui n'arrive pas à en sortir et
donc mécaniquement on se retrouve avec
finalement le sentiment d'être piégé et
donc effectivement d'être déclassé
notamment par rapport à ses parents où
on sait pendant les les générations
anciennes avaent un accès au logement
qui était un petit peu plus facilité
même s'ils avaient des taux très très
élevés à l'époque hein alors il y il y a
plusieurs questions que j'ai j'ai
annoncé en préambule de de ce débat
est-ce que c'est une crise historique on
y a en grande partie répondu les leviers
qu'on pouvait activer on a commencé à y
répondre et puis a la question est-ce
que c'est une crise mondiale ou Franco
française je vous propose d'accueillir
tout de suite Steve Jourdain pour
répondre à cette question rebonsoir
Steve en fait elle touche toute l'Europe
cette crise oui vous avez déjà rêvé
d'acquérir une cage d'escalier en plein
longas pas vraiment mais j'attends de
voir ce que ça donne jeis vous montrer
ce produit puis on en reparle juste
après voilà vous voyez c'est très belle
cage d'escalier c'est à l'achat ça àance
alors une belle luminosité oui quand
même ouais vous êtes
bon et tout ça pour la Monix somme de
23000 € 23000 € c'est presque donné
c'est une grande cage d'escalier
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait c'est ça alors
vous pouvez pas l'aménager parce qu'il
faudra ensuite obtenir un permis de
construire mais déjà voilà vous obtenez
cette cage d'escalier pour 23000 € plus
sérieusement cette annonce elle est très
sérieuse a beaucoup fait réagir les
Britanniques il y a quelques mois c'est
le symbole d'un marché immobilier devenu
complètement fou à Londres en 15 ans les
prix ont été multipliés par plus de TR
et c'est pas seulement au Royaume-Uni
s'emball un peu partout pr oui dans
ensemble de l'Union européenne les prix
de vente de l'immobilier ont explosé
entre 2015 et 2021 plus 40 % en moyenne
si vous voulez acheter un appartement à
Prague il vous faudra économiser en
moyenne 20 années de salaire si votre
truc c'est plutôt Oslo ou Rome il vous
faudra sacrifier votre salaire pendant
au moins 10 ans allez on rentre dans les
explications comment on peut expliquer
ce phénomène alors il y a plusieurs
facteurs he déjà la construction ne suit
pas la demande ce qui provoque une
pénerie de logement et contribue et bien
à augmenter les prix en Allemagne par
exemple le nombre de permis de
construire délivré au 1er semestre 2023
a chuté de 27 % en cause notamment la
hausse des coûts de construction plus de
36 % en 3 ans problèmes
d'approvisionnement en matièrees
premières pénurie de main d'œuvre crise
énergétique tout cela contribue et bien
à tirer les coups vers le haut résultat
des dépôts de bilan de plusieurs
sociétés de construction ici c'est un
chantier à Hambourg qui a été interrompu
au mois de novembre la société signa a
mis la clé sous la porte avant d'avoir
achevé sa mission autre facteur
important Thal l'augmentation des taux
d'intérêt dans la zone euro elle a été
décidée par la Banque centrale
européenne 10 augmentations de suite en
l'espace d'un an en clair l'argent est
beaucoup plus cher aujourd'hui et c'est
une politique assumée par la patronne de
la
BCE nous sommes déterminés à faire en
sorte que l'inflation revienne
rapidement à notre objectif de 2 % à
moyen terme sur la base de notre
évaluation actuelle nous considérons que
les taux d'intérêt directeurs de la BCE
se situe à des niveaux qui s'ils sont
maintenus pendant une période
suffisamment longue contribueront de
manière substantielle à la réalisation
de cet objectif pour l'instant pas de
crash immobilier à prévoir selon les
experts dans la zone euro mais des
conséquences très concrètes vous en
parliez tout à l'heure les loyers
flambent un peu partout en Europe et les
jeunes ont de plus en plus de mal à
trouver un logement merci beaucoup Steve
Jourdain pour toutes ces informations je
vais je vais reposer pierre mal je me
tourne vers vous une question qu'on a
évoqué tout à l'heure mais finalement on
n pas vraiment répondu je reprends le ce
qui s'est passé à Hambourg là cette
société c'est une grosse société de de
promotion immobilière si je ne me trompe
qui a qui a mis la clé sous la porte et
comment vont les sociétés françaises en
la matière là on parle du neuf hein des
des logements neuf c'est c'est dis
est-ce qu'il peut y avoir des plans
sociaux dans les prochains dans dans les
prochaines semaines alors oui il peut il
peut y en avoir après euh ce qui est
intéressant les les les hétérogénités
territoriales ont été déjà mentionné on
se doute bien qu'une petite boîte de
promotion immobilière qui travaille dans
la maison individuelle
va potentiellement moins bien survivre à
la crise qu'on traverse que les gros
promoteurs qui continuent et qui
réussissent à à construire du logement
dans les zones les les plus chères ce
qui est intéressant avec ce qui vient
d'être dit c'est que c'est quoi les
points communs des des villes où en gros
ça va mal le marché c'est emballé c'est
c'est des villes où on a beaucoup de mal
à produire du logement neuf parce qu'il
y a des contraintes foncières c'est des
villes qui sont déjà denses ça c'est sur
la partie offre de de logement et c'est
des villes qu'on a dont on a entretenu
l'attractivité pendant extrêmement
longtemps c'est Paris Prague Berlin
Lisbonne et dans une situation de de de
crise très importante on entretient
l'attractivité on crée des emplois on
incite les touristes à venir de plus en
plus donc du coup on enlève des des
logement du marché standard à l'année
avec la mise en location sur les
plateformes tout ça participe à à la
fois un dynamisme très important de la
demande et on n'arrive pas évidemment à
suivre au niveau de l'offre parce qu'on
est extrêmement contraint donc il y a
aussi des choix d' aménagement du
territoire et de de métropolisation de
l'activité qui sont en cause sur des
temps très longs ou Matthieu je deux
question est-ce que le le diagnostic
énergétique fait baisser les prix parce
que on imagine que dans l'ancien tous
les logements sont pas forcément classés
au top niveau est-ce que quand on a une
mauvaise note ça fait baisser parle du
DP du Diagnos per per a peur de la note
F ou G voil et la deè question c'est
est-ce que le projet de zéro
artificialisation nette des sols c'est
qui consiste à rendre qu'on lui prend en
terme de surface est-ce que ça ça va pas
bloquer le alors deux thèmes on commence
par le DPE pierre madek avec vous puis
peut-être ensuite je vais jeis je suis
pas un professionnel de l'immobilier
dans le sens où je je me charge pas de
la vente des appartements ce que dis ce
que disent a beaucoup de passir énergéti
en ce que dis les professionnels c'est
qu'en effet il y a de plus en plus un
impact du DPE le risque c'est que du
coup on crée deux marchés le marché des
passoirs qui serait accessible à au
ménag les plus modestes qui aurait pas
forcément les moyens de faire des
travaux et puis le marché des logements
de bonne qualité qui serait accessible
au reste de la population donc il y a un
vrai risque de de dichotomie du marché
immobilier de ce point de v-l ouais CRA
bien a est-ce que cette mesure le DPE
elle elle elle produit ou elle crée
euh les craintes on les comprend mais
disproportionné chez les propriétaires
d'après vous il y a une question de
rythme en fait à quel rythme on va on va
imposer disproportionné non parce que
c'est c'est c'est quand même des
montants importants pour pouvoir changer
de note en fait sur le dans le de DP il
faut faire des travaux assez importants
il faut faire des bouquets de de de de
de de rénovation pas seulement les
fenêtres mais les fenêtres le toit et
cetera donc c'est des budgets qui au
niveau individuel pour les bailleurs
peuvent être compliqués à à porter donc
non c'est c'est normal que les
propriétaire se s'inquiète puisqueen
fait quand ils ont acheté leur logement
ils avaient pas tous forcément en tête
qu'ils allaient devoir l'entretenir et
ça c'est souvent un problème sur
l'accession à la propriété c'estàdire
qu'on valorise beaucoup le fait de
devenir propriétaire mais il y a pas que
le coût de l'accession et ensuite tout
le cût derrière de de de de de travail
sur l'investissement en fait pour qu'il
reste en de bonne qualité ouais et et
donc ça pose et ça rejoint la question
sur le le le zan le zéro
artificialisation euh net claire juiller
est-ce qu'il y a là une une
contradiction ou des injonction
contradictoire entre les impératifs
environnementaux et finalement la le
l'état de santé du marché du du logement
je peux dire ça différemment est-ce que
le marché du logement est trop fragile
pour supporter euh euh la la la la
révolution ou le ou la transformation
environnementale qu'il faut faire euh je
sais pas s'il est trop fragile il est
peut-être pas encore suffisamment
structuré mais il est en passe de le
devenir il s'organise les les acteurs se
mettent au pas s'organisent montent en
compétence sur des sujets notamment de
requalification de rénovation euh pour
préserver effectivement la
consomationespace des matériaux et CER
absolument euh voilà après c'est un
processus euh un petit peu long il faut
réinventer les modèles euh il faut
chercher les compétences il faut former
euh il faut mettre au pas l'ensemble des
parties prenantes on parlait des des
propriétaires mais en fait rénover une
copropriété à l'échelle de la
copropriété il y a encore d'autres
enjeux des difficultés de prise de
décision qu'il faut surmonter tout ça
mérite du temps de la pédagogie des
moyens euh il y a un dernier thème don
il nous reste quelques minutes pas
beaucoup mais il y a un dernier thème
don dont je voudrais parler c'est la la
réalité je commence à avec vous Sandra
Wian de euh de l'effet postcovid est-ce
que oui ou non il y a il y a eu un
mouvement euh vers des villes plus
petites des maisons avec jardins des
appartements avec terrasses et cetera et
cetera ou est-ce que ça a été un un feu
de paille non il y a eu il y a eu un
mouvement mais pas aussi grand que ce
qu'on l'a dit et pas exactement comme on
l'a décrit c'est-à-dire que dans les
médias on a beaucoup vu des urbain qui
partaient s'installer en plein milieu de
nulle part avec presque leur git voilà
c'est c'est pas ça qui s'est passé ce
qui s'est passé c'est plutôt un petit
peu on allit habiter un petit peu plus
loin en périphérie donc pour avoir des
logements un peu plus grands notamment
grâce au télétravail mais il faut
rappeler que le télétravail c'est
essentiellement des cadres donc en gros
les 2/ers des actifs n'ont pas accès au
télétravail donc métropolisation on a
agrandi les métropoles et
littoralisation c'està-dire que on est
aller un petit peu plus s'installer sur
des dans des coins qui sont plutôt
agréable et qui était déjà en fait des
tendances qui précédaient le le le covid
donc l'histoire était pas compl
complètement fausse mais elle était
beaucoup accentuée claire j ça veut dire
que ça a concerné une petite partie de
la population française la la capacité
de de de faire ses choix de quitter les
de quitter les grandes villes de d'aller
chercher un peu de ouou
Pera la souligner effectivement ça ça
dépend notamment de la capacité à à à
télétravailler ça dépend bah de la
situation globale du ménage et cetera
donc effectivement on a par estce que ça
aurit pu rééquilibrer pardon de de vous
interrompre et de de d'enrichir j'espère
ma ma question est-ce que si ce
mouvement était plus profond ça aurait
pu rééquilibrer ou ou sauver le le le
marché du logement mais c'est un peu
c'est un peu le type de projection qu'on
a faite et et là pour le coup sous un
sous sous l'effet de la crise euh mais
effectivement quand on regarde à la fois
les transactions ou les mobilités
résidentielles qui ont pu se se réaliser
dans ce contexte de crise et depuis mais
et quand on regarde aussi la manière
dont se sont projetés et se projettent
depuis les Français dans l'espace
géographique de la France ce qu'on
constate c'est effectivement alors on
est
loin d'un phénomène d'exode urbain on
est plutôt effectivement dans le
renforcement de tendances préexistantes
sachant que ce que je voudrais souligner
je pense c'est important de de de
l'ajouter au débat si je peux dire c'est
que les mouvements qu'on a pu repérer ou
les projets de enfin de de de
de d'achat ou de prise à bail qu'on a pu
repérer il concernait pas uniquement des
mouvements qui allaient dans le sens de
la prise à bail ou de l'achat d'une
résidence principale euh c'était pas mal
de résidence secondaire oui en fait dans
les mouvements qu'on a pu repérer et et
suivre à la trace on avait des
mouvements qui étaient favorables à la
résidence principale et d'autres qui
étaient favorables à la résidence
secondaire voire même à l'investissement
locatif dans la perspective euh du
passage d'un passage à la retraite voilà
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat qui était
passionnant voilà c'est la fin de ce
numéro de sens public euh je vous donne
rendez-vous euh demain émission spéciale
consacrée à la conférence d'Emmanuel
Macron à l'Élysée on sera là à 18h euh
voilà pour pour l'annoncer il y a
également les vœux le discours des vœux
du président du Sénat gérrard Larcher et
puis euh euh on débriefera la conférence
alors combien de temps ça va durer ma
monsieur vous serez pas là pour le vivre
avec nous mais celle du programme
présidentiel avit duré 4 heur bon ben
voilà donc je sais pas jusqu'à quelle
heure on sera là demain soir mais on
sera là pour débriefer merci à tous
Notter que l'invité Doriane mansini
demain matin sur notre antenne ce sera
Patrick caner le président du groupe
socialiste au Sénat belle
[Musique]
soirée